[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
there we go
you guys should be able to hear us uh we
don't we're not on face cans today and
we're on the uh the standard mics so the
audio is going to take a little bit of a
hit uh but you guys uh will be fine
you'll live
uh the uh
can you hear us King hello hello
everybody
to your controller
all right so so this is how this is
gonna work guys
originally we were going to do like an
hour of the the round table an hour of
this
uh but now I just let's just do them
both together you know I have the Q a
thing up uh it's up at the top uh I
don't know how it looks from your guyses
in because I've never actually seen it
on like as a viewership thing but from
what it seems like to me you just click
it you type what you want to ask you
click submit and it pops over on my end
as a question and you know we we will
take pauses and answer all the questions
that's in there I got a couple general
questions that I got from like Twitter
and stuff uh but you know we first off I
want to thank everyone uh for you know
we we hit that we hit the 25 of the
packs go
and we about to hit 50. all right yo so
uh Tom sorry my apologies I will be back
you guys can do three ways or whatever
pause
um
I play with your joystick now I know why
he beats
coming together
I shall return
three ways
incredible this look bad good this is
[Music]
good I haven't seen one of these joints
in a while yeah Rey Mysterio look like
Rey Mysterio crazy
Breakers are skillful candles that you
can perform too bad they got whack uh
Russell is that nobody you have to click
at the top and you have to click ask the
Lord stuff so I can make sure that
everyone's questions get asked I know
you know I know it's it's a new it's a
new feature and a lot of people don't
utilize it a lot but if you ask it over
there I know it needs to be asked I'm
not going to be looking at the chat a
whole lot I'll glance over there from
time to time but if you want to have
questions you have to ask that q a thing
you can't just put it in the chat
because that chat
in in 10 minutes I'll lose your message
so just be sure you guys put it in that
q a point oh is these bum wrestlers
[Music]
what do you guys want to do
I want to get a chance to get to my
Goldberg that's what I want to do I
don't know what the hell
he better be uh somebody gotta find
something for me to play with Paul and
it ain't gonna be these whack rappers
they got oh man
attraction The Killers
okay
oh he's still doing damn like he doing
all these rolling balls gonna be chill
ing
right yeah you got to do this nah he's
nah now I'm not doing this hold on man
let me back out of this get out of this
all right challenge
yeah he's doing that I'm choosing these
these stupid Stars these things that
they call Stars
the other day
let's coach this fake culture
spent yeah
then one more performance offensive
action
new boss for situational paybacks
uh okay
that seems the key to any wrestler's
success is strong fundamentals nobody
knows more about fundamentals actually
I'm good yeah
and show some aggression yeah light
strikes are the fastest moves you have
let's do heavy attacks deal big damage
capitalized
heavy strike
for any wrestler wow
for the Press right
oh go down and right analog is fifth
yes it's called you here
what's up ducky
what the hell with this thing right here
I want to play pause
in the rain
ah they give you participating
trophies
no yes
no no not a good look yo
where is the dudes at
his eye they're countless styles
you have to pay for like a DLC or
something
well I gotta go buy them so he's gonna
get bought today
oh that is all right they go rumbles uh
handicap match Creations showcase
all right hold on all right so go to
that so let me go to one on one that's
not normal all right
what is this
high flyer male AJ Styles
I'm about to go purchase they say
purchase
because yo you gotta look at the wagons
they got Damien free
when he was young
come on man these all sound like porno
flick guys
talk all this about wrestling and I know
who these people are and you guys don't
well
but you will never know who for rock is
though but I do it I don't need to I
know all the Korean people
I know all the oldies that are mopped
the floor with all of them at one time
hahaha
Fandango who the hell is that
I gotta do things
[Applause]
they gotta do they Titus O'Neill all
right there you go I Gotta Buy Goldberg
There He Go he's a thousand dollars all
right okay what are you doing up there
100 squats
yes yes oh they got Triple H oh they got
two undertakers they got the long ride
oh
yeah
they forcing me to make this faction
all right all right so when you go like
go to the roster and go to pick the
one-on-ones right
um all right so put it on one to one
right like you just go play just go play
do you want to leave my faction yes I
want to leave this shirt okay here we go
I'm at the I'm thinking about the screen
home creation just go play yeah
one-on-one okay one-on-one okay
then go normal
okay
just buy a 70s name porn
I heard she's crazy
but they just I just see these whack
cards that I have I don't know
so hold on let me finish buying the last
dude the last dude is gonna be Ultimate
Warrior uh purchased all right
this is
one on one right
don't know I'm at home go
play yeah
now they're gonna tell you go pick your
guy
right
who should I go to God and then go down
right oh okay all right now as you go
down in the joint just pick one of those
ones that's faded out yeah they got a
little picture
yeah now it'll let you go bye now you
got four thousand dollars right I got it
without cash at
I gotta
I got a thousands
son this is 88. Goldberg is 88. don't
worry about that let me see who let's do
the top dude
ought to take the 92
yeah how old Warriors
[Music]
come here
why Facebook man oh he's he's twice a
manager and uh heavy yeah oh there go
Goldberg Goldberg's 88 yeah
they did Sean Michael's dirty you got it
yeah Michael son they got him oh they
don't even got young Sean Michaels
Shawn Michaels
what do you guys want to play
I don't think so
I mean solve yeah I don't think Saul's
coming back
um
I kind of want to do a like a like a
small Royal Rumble I don't know why yeah
he could do that oh there you go
hold up the locker room the girls yo
this is it right here if if we ever had
something to look like this growing up
oh it would have been over we would have
never left the house
oh my God who is Broad strobin
ation
I just want to see how they come to the
ring while we while you setting up the
match
oh
this is okay we stream is a oh okay no
doubt no
yeah yeah
so we back we back to this to WWE
Heavyweight Champion
they got the rundown okay
[Music]
who jumped in
they got the young one
outside
they've got the um face paint a little
off though
no
I thought it was so complicated I'm
pretty sure Michael said yo the entrance
is
God body yeah
that's just a really good and they they
look like they 60 frames yes they are
bling this is clean
who is Braun strowman
why is he walking to the ring like that
I'm not doing none of those new rappers
oh sure Michael do I show Michael that
might be the weekend Destiny killer
the weekend Destiny killer
well I still gotta finish my campaign in
Destiny I was doing it
when I was doing it under a guided name
of Invisible Man
yeah it was good do any classic or
you're doing legendary it's a boy toy
yo Rob remember this
oh oh they got Shawn Michaels looking
terrible
all right we coming home
yo this looks really good all right
block off front
we got a question
from uh beta Cipher thoughts on what's
the update for the Activision deal
um it is what it is it's about to go
down yeah it's about to go down it's
only about to have to pay
yeah I I think what I'm more interested
in is is the fact that Sony has to has
to reveal some classified documents
that's what I want to see
I want to know you talk about the
exclusivity deal Jack yeah I want to see
what those are because you know even if
those aren't going to be public you know
they're going to end up being public so
what was the question
thoughts on the update
oh which update on the activation
might be going down
yep
now remember guys oh if you want to ask
questions you got to ask
the you got to do it in the the QA part
you got to ask in there uh we got a
couple popping in but you have to ask in
there
oh this is it oh boy sure
I don't know yet
I had to leave my match I was I was
getting worked over yeah let me go let
me go let me go yeah we got the people
wait I got your invite right now I'm
coming
I already got Brock Lesnar
I can't
I couldn't I'm sorry brother sorry all
right I'm in there I want to know how I
got 4 000.
Josh was good man fast cash was good
I dare you how dare you come in here
with him Jamie ain't here
ah
jump look we gotta Jump The Rock first
yeah it always Jump The Rock oh
that is
we have what you call it here we have
Sinister we act like Celestine channel
five
soon
oh I didn't you should have let me know
I would have been back up anytime for
this you know I'm down for this yeah
yeah but do it in the background do the
background download it as fast as you
could
all right I'll put it right now
this is what is but this is the old one
though this is the
fun with that this is
well we sharing so 2K 22 you should have
it
yeah he said it was I was thinking of
picking it up because it was like 17
bucks the other day
I was looking at it but the new one came
out because everyone's about to come out
I think that's what it is it sucks
because we paid for it last year
um when it was new it was new and you
know dude's just running from playing
yeah
so now if I would have known y'all were
dead I would have I would have picked it
up no problem
you had it anyway
we're gonna jump you so we gotta let
these intros go you gotta let the engine
yeah
don't skip the intros let me live right
no pun intended because you know I
wasted 35 minutes on just getting
together
Triple Threat action with The Rock
[Applause]
sure
in a matchup like this course
[Applause]
thank you
how do you ride
there you go there you go
[Applause]
they need to switch the focus but I
don't know
[Applause]
the warrior doctor
beautiful
[Applause]
we all back
oh
[__] we got sit in here
the gays
[Applause]
well yeah
oh
[Applause]
the arm clutch
he almost did it
oh my god
get directions
[Applause]
you know
Ultimate Warrior in a little bit of
trouble here
[Applause]
I think it is triple threat is triple
threat
[Applause]
he's now
stand there
[Applause]
oh come on man that was about to finish
it
[Applause]
pick a warrior
are they they have double walls
[Applause]
what happened what happened what
happened
nah bro
oh it happens something popped up and I
pressed a something popped up it is the
match quick
we're still playing
oh you in it yeah
I just
and all these people not showing up on
you
yeah I'm still fighting I started
another uh party all right
um the rock is taking the elbow
God
I don't know I don't know how that
happened a network yeah I don't know
what happened
Network area
yeah the rock is
tap out all the rock beat us
I didn't leave my guy behind I don't
know what happened like something popped
up during the fight yes because I was
pressing option
uh what's up what's your favorite WWE
game of all time from Hollywood's
probably uh what is it no mercy yeah
yeah where'd you see any questions
oh actually let me back back out and
re-send them because I'll give you guys
your entrances because I think I see how
you can yeah you turned the intros off
it's by default they're all
ah we can't have that
all right
uh the they're on the uh
like you have to actually click them to
see them you have to be on the IOP
Channel
yo they can't protect your back as a
it's the titles what is what is your
guys's favorite WWE game of all time
yeah
for the N64 I just don't remember which
one it was like
revenge for me
I don't need that
but you see that
I got some Facebook music in the
background so who did you pick my I
picked Smackdown do you pick Raw
or something
this is two or two steel cage
exactly so you don't get jealous
[Laughter]
the rule in their house is kill a rock
that's the rule in the house Son
by his player though right yeah I got so
I got to pick somebody else I gotta go
buy somebody go buy somebody
yeah
it doesn't impression
no it's not letting me I was trying to
because it's not let him do it in this
man you hear because he didn't he had to
do it before he enjoyed the match yeah
back out we got to back out to the title
screen so we can allow himself he could
back out yeah
like eight times I wanna see what's up
with him I'll be right back he said uh
he said just buy the 70s name porn ma is
it why car dressed like a stripper from
the hood
he said can you enable live stream so we
can watch on the Xbox
um yeah it's on live stream
all you got to do is go to
um uh what you call it you're gonna see
it it's gonna pop up but what happened
was uh where am I going to purchase and
it kicked out
okay no you tell a guy
yeah
no no
you just go like you're gonna go play
the regular play one-on-one and then
when you go to pick your man to fight
you're gonna see them grayed out and you
just click on them and then from there
you could pick you could then buy the
person with the with the gold all right
so okay hold on we have a uh Julio said
what game would you bet on being
announced for the fall avowed hellblade
or something else
I think you'll see like at E3 you'll see
both but I don't think uh valve's coming
out this year
yeah I definitely agree with that
foreign
Fest
yeah
we played a whole lot of wrestle fast oh
yeah now remember guys when I'm on the
question thing I can't see the chat so
if you're asking questions I can't see
you're gonna have to go to the actual
page and click uh and ask the question
they're gonna protect your neck yeah
yeah they're gonna protect your neck
and click the up Arrow at the top the
down arrow no say questions live chat or
top chat and you have to click uh
questions
you see what it says q a ask the Lord
stuff yes you have to uh go into the uh
into the the directory and then when
you're in there where you see like uh
you know how long it's been streaming
the title oh okay then you click at the
top right like the YouTube Studio yeah
all right do you have to reinvite me to
the game to the session yeah sure
I forgot how quick the party feels when
we all appear online
[Music]
I'm I'm in the Giant
I'm in the this YouTube studio now where
yeah at the uh you know how the chat's
in the right
yeah if you click the the down arrow
above the chat
it will say questions yeah ah there we
go okay yup I see it now there we go oh
here we go
yes execution
yeah
tornado tag team steel K so we TR hold
up yo check this out check it out check
it out check out the interview
in Iraq
oh
brother
actually the chat doesn't hear the music
[Applause]
play your favorite music in the
background and just things
um
[Applause]
uh it was Chris Benoit
I had to had to put that together
[Applause]
I'm a big fan of Brett
um after that I'm a big fan of array
Mysterio
um yeah so those are my favorites there
yeah I'm sorry no no not all time is uh
yeah this is that
um
[Applause]
it's Chris Benoit
here we go
yeah hello
[Applause]
like a dragon
so yeah my top five will be uh Warrior
I like Kurt Angle
of course I liked so many people Chris
Jericho yeah trying to think two more so
many
[Applause]
[Music]
Undertaker that's right Undertaker a
Goldberg
um you know I do love the Ultimate
Warrior but I gotta respect uh though so
I'm gonna have to go with uh Jake
um Macho Man and the last one
million dollars
oh he moving they normally don't have a
movie Fast yeah
Batman
[Applause]
they did this right here
that's the uh
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
has a devastating weapon
look at me
[Applause]
um
[Music]
Goldberg
let's do it over here
[Applause]
just go back
he can handle the intensity
[Applause]
oh my God
[Music]
what the heck
leave him Rocky yeah
[Applause]
I was not defeated at the Continental
champion
[Applause]
over there
thank you
let's do it let's do it again we will do
nothing
[Applause]
of Jesus
Jesus Christ
[Applause]
get his keys
no surprise that what we're witnessing
is trending look at trending on social
media I don't think it's over it's not
over
wait a second wait a second how come I
can't get my mask off
[__]
[Applause]
I'm stuck here
oh no okay so listen listen when you you
should leave they don't let you know
[Applause]
oh yeah
that's a fighting double
measure
[Applause]
you absolutely
oh Ultimate Warrior
[Applause]
get out of here
oh yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh man
oh my God
open the warrior in the stomach he don't
do everything
back again
[Applause]
here he goes
the cage
[Applause]
thank you
who's sitting in this Arena
[Applause]
how you feel it I do with the with the R
button with the um bumper but then you
get to the top I don't know what the
house
together so close to the very peak of
the Steelers
[Applause]
he's gonna have to try something else
now
buster
[Applause]
it is over
here
[Applause]
[Music]
controller
[Applause]
oh my God
come on Rock Eagle
[Applause]
Rock come here
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah
we stay intact we stay intact
I gotta find another dude hold on hold
on hold on
make it make it a four-way just
straightforward like Yeah Boy no tag
pause with this forward
we picking backup wrestlers are we
picking up our dudes are good I'm
picking my dude no I'm picking up
oops
Stone Cold Steve Austin man
sorry brother
Triple H sorry yo I would love to see
what Triple H intro is
[Music]
taco
I drive Frozen
this is 202 steel cage yeah
[Laughter]
it's frozen up
why
it says 212 steel cage but then can't
press nothing
I'm gonna quit your son's going on
I don't see attic there that's why
um
it kind of froze up yeah it did turn it
right out
you have to quit and then reload it
yeah that was actually fun
I told you those are the best drugs ever
wrestling games the beach that we used
to have every week yeah I ain't gonna
lie addict Addie had the courage cause
he was so sick and tired of sovereign
[Laughter]
Rubble
and they keep sending people in
yeah
weird numbers it would be weird but see
the options of single player multiplayer
I think is two different things but let
me look okay
let me see if I can buy somebody else
for them
you could do Battle Royale throw the
other Superstar over the top rope and be
the last one in the room to win is he
done with me
you guys want to do that thank you
oh go Mommy go eat go Mommy go eat
they don't got a lot of old school
wrestlers close the door you probably
got to buy them from the store yeah they
probably like TLC or something yeah
oh they did short Michael's dirty you
see how he looks wow that boy looks
pretty much on Michael's that's why no
that's disgusting they caught him on the
Geritol run yeah
looks horrid
yo let me cancel out of this game
foreign
oh
send an invite ready sorry 100 Giant
hold on I'm just trying to buy another
uh character they have some of the
iconic Dukes like I don't see this thing
I didn't see this thing but I didn't
look at it yeah this thing's in there I
saw him sting is in here yeah somewhere
uh
yep the first thing this is big
I didn't feel
I think this game is more about fairness
because the other games that we used to
play like the hockey game I understand
yeah it wasn't about no fear in this boy
that joint Booker T
you send the invite I took it but it
didn't take me to you which is stupid
thank you
okay oh there you go anything right hold
on a second oh yeah I have it this is
Ubisoft right
oh this is a 2K
but I mean uh the the Publishers Ubisoft
right no yo because I don't see
Sovereign here
no here don't you see yeah I'm trying to
buy another character hold on yeah
he he he's in there but it's a community
thing it's not like enough yeah hear me
though yeah yeah we hear you okay
machine
you know what it is
I'm gonna go with old school Undertaker
let's do that
Undertaker was just
pure Savage yeah when there was when
there was no staying there was
undertaking
I'm not selling anything
no sound none of your moves
tell me how Brock Lesnar is a 94.
yo you should take pride when he I took
him oh okay here we go all right send it
again send it again
since we doing that nah nah you know
what it is
you know what it is
he was gone for a minute
probably bought like the whole roster
oh
oh yeah
oh you got Undertaker too
see
so I was like did I just spent five
dollars for no reason
I could have took the other Undertaker I
could have I broke both of them
oh you bought 90s
that's my dude
if they would have mean marker by Mean
Mark too me Mark canis
[Applause]
[Laughter]
like a million people
[Applause]
[Music]
title Reigns he's also one of the hearts
and minds of the WWE news
[Applause]
he's gonna do a lot of movies
at 323 pounds when he first showed up
he didn't have the mouth
yeah yeah right yeah yeah I guess he was
dying over there
[Applause]
I remember the heat coming from the um
yeah
you're the best of the trolls
[Applause]
and demise
edit this
is
crazy
just
of the dead man
yeah this is after he came back from
ride a bike
I want to be dead man
look at the crowd the crowd look crazy
those spoke effects
50 frames dear God yeah there's
difference with 60 frames or at the
trucks we never had that yeah we did
we did man
yeah
they threw the hdr on
oh yo he activated the HDR you know
Undertaker is a time-honored
this HDR is crazy dude I'm not sure
[Applause]
we're gonna have to rest in peace on TV
thank you
after the headline
yeah wow
they did they did the whole thing we're
not gonna sit through mine
[Applause]
for him
I wonder if they have it differently
though yeah I wonder if that one is
different right it better be two
different ones
he was riding the bike
they better put the polygons on it
because it's the same hold on yeah
Escape was the same thing yeah
I forgot we were sitting there so long I
forgot what the batch was
I don't know which one I don't know
which one
[Applause]
I mean the last ones I think I'm the one
yeah
[Applause]
Believe It or Not patience is a virtue
sometimes it takes a little Looney
in that case you need to accelerate your
own intensity of course remember
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
TLC matches are inherently dangerous he
was ready for this
wow
I don't know how to do anything I think
it's the right I think it's the right
right analog oh right yeah
Undertaker retaliates
Lucina
[Applause]
oh
this is the advantage after a string of
cows
oh [__]
[Applause]
on him there
[Music]
[Applause]
he's open
up
here we go
somebody got it
outside
[Applause]
it is the left trigger
oh there you go he climbs into the ring
yeah that's kind of unintuitive very
unintuitive
thank you
oh no
dude
[Applause]
get off my brother
I like that boom
bro
[Applause]
he leaves the ring and there's no
cutouts in this one
he's creeping
[Applause]
oh
thank you
[Applause]
come on come on get it together
there we go
Undertaker
[Applause]
come here come here
yes
[Applause]
oh damn it
again
straight in the crew
punch right in the head
oh
and now there's an opening
listen to this place
you worked the way out of here
she walked through it
s position
[Applause]
hits him with the county
it's fun
it's back into the ring goodness that
hurt the shoulder he is just completely
lost his
WinCo
[Applause]
big red is down but is he out
Head Over Heels finish
[Applause]
oh
yeah
[Applause]
needs to pull out some of that fire oh
he's in danger of losing this matchup
yeah
what energy in the arena time he's been
placed in the corner
do not lose
[Applause]
nosy
yeah
why am I on Street
you know what I want
oh
it's coming from taker Jesus
[Applause]
oh no
much
[Applause]
all right
the unbelievable
yeah
[Applause]
all right
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
looking beatable
I'm dead I'm dead no
[Applause]
no seven vintage
driver nailed it oh oh they got that oh
down down let's go attraction
[Applause]
okay there you go there you go
knuckles
[Applause]
get this dude
that's what it takes to put the Dead Man
Down
[Applause]
and at this point he's risking permanent
injury
for the drop oh
that's what I waited
are you ready
to figure out how to use the ladder wins
too many translated
that is true
[Applause]
get that letter for him oh he threw it
on my head oh my God
no abdomen
I got a head scratches
now
[Applause]
Adam got to take the matches he's just
open red monsters
oh
[Applause]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[__] yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
popped up
being no let me finish this
can we just pick up this damn ladder
let's go
how you do that with the a button
we go
[Applause]
I don't know the first L he hit the
ladder
oh there you go
push it
[Applause]
yo I can't do anything
good
[Applause]
how did you get it to do that b
oh
[Applause]
golly hey
I wanted to get up on that Rider
I'm trying to get him Undertaker
counters
is it not set to the middle of the Ring
that's the chance of it yeah
[Applause]
look how he configuring the ladder
you can do a real bad work out here
desperate attempt here to get back
[Applause]
guys
you guys
option
there you go
that was a stupid mini game up there
stupid mini game it's a mini game you
gotta do it yeah
right now
[Applause]
nothing left
again
[Applause]
nasty
ah
[Applause]
that's okay
can't do it
[Applause]
he's finished
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
thank you
an adjustment that has got to be the one
how many specials he got
oh God
I'll ramp it out for five minutes
I heard that stupid stuff
he turns it around
what's he open a fight down there yeah
I guess he thinks the one thing missing
in this match
[Applause]
oh my god
there you go there you go come on
offense
[Applause]
[Music]
the big red monster has been
historically difficult I don't know how
you'll find yourself under the ring we
know
it comes back into the ring
getting set up for something in the
corner Undertaker retaliates
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
nick of time
[Applause]
oh he almost did perfect
pause
[Applause]
I'm done
Jesus
looking to Vanquish the devil's favorite
and now yo this is
[Applause]
nice tonight
cheers
yeah okay so that's a double tap he
steps foot of the Ring again
[Applause]
you miss me huh son
Undertaker
uppercut
they said you got to turn blood onto the
options
[Applause]
ah yeah go for the goose
thank you
he gave out
let's go ahead with this
numbers
[Applause]
what's in the box
oh
yeah I have no idea
[Applause]
you go up with the right bumper herself
can make all the difference
[Applause]
shorty what you drink
what happened
fortnite
uh
people was asking me to stream wabu on
uh on uh wulong
all right you can do that later
video yo I'll talk to you
yeah
we got one question real quick what's
the question that game should be 30.
um I I recently installed it on my brand
new computer I've been playing it
ah
it's just you know what it is I'm still
early so I have a lot of the same moves
I haven't unlocked moves and stuff yet
it's it it is
oh no bro hey just all they needed to do
was make a good a good quarterballs game
and maybe the story's there I'm hoping
but the gameplay stuff so far I'm down
to play it so I've got to send it
I don't know if you want to play it on
Console I really don't yes I do because
I'm not playing it on PC I can tell you
that
face
I don't I don't know that it's playable
on Console that's what I mean
he's trying to act like it ain't
playable because he got the twelve
thousand dollars
you know what it is they don't have so
far right I'm playing with Batgirl
because he's the most like Batman they
don't have the counter the they don't
have that the free flow combat it's not
there it's just if she can go from enemy
to enemy but it's not that smooth
counter going to the next one do my
stuff jump into the it doesn't seem to
have that at all and that's
that's not what you want from that game
like uh same same as with Suicide Squad
I don't know we'll see we'll see but
they might fix Suicide Squad we never
know
yeah we'll see but that's it I played it
and that look I've heard the story is
decent we will see I don't know if I'll
get that photo I don't really care show
the void log shout out more Jesus Christ
sir duck
oh man it's in the chat one-on-one
salute yeah CNS rock out
where's the monkey head
I'm out of here fellas hi brother talk
to y'all later in a minute
who's texting me like Matt
what's up
[Music]
thank you
uh
that was fun though
yeah oh yeah
who do I have on Epic
wow a lot of people's on
Jungle Jack is playing I'll probably get
off though King I I haven't really slept
much
oh go to bed bro all right man I'll talk
to you later
catch you in a minute
see you guys uh appreciate everyone for
coming through